Đôi giao viên mạnh nó, nhỏ vưởng lương thấp nhất được biểu trình từ bỗ trình lên 6 phẩy ba trường đồng mũ tháng,
tăng gần 4.000 đồng, nhỏ mắc các nhất từ 1 phẩy trình lên 7 phẩy mũ trường đồng, tăng 1 phẩy hai trường đồng.
Giao viên theo học cho cửa sở cho phủ thông và giám bien đại học, cao đằng Trung Quốc, người hưởng lương thấp nhất tăng từ 6 phẩy năm,
lên 6 phẩy trường đồng. Cào nhất từ 1 phẩy trình lên 7 phẩy hai trường đồng.
Qua tiên lương trên nhà giáo còn được hưởng một số loại phục cấp như phục cấp thâm miền nhà giáo,
phủ cấp đủ đảy theo nghề đủ đủ đủ nhà giáo, chục tiếp giảng giời, các cấp học muốn học lối tưởng dậy học và theo phục miền tông tác.
Theo người định 1 tháng 2 năm 2 ngày tù trọng hàng sấu chính phủ, tương em 1 tháng bây, phủ cấp đủ đảy theo nghề của một số nhóm nhà giáo,
được nâng từ 7 phẩy trăm lên 4 phẩy trăm, từ 6 phẩy trăm lên 6 phẩy trăm lên 6 phẩy trăm lên 6 phẩy trăm,
trong đó nhà giáo giảng giời tại cơ sở, tạo giúp 1 nón và trường tều học,
được hưởng phục cấp yêu đảy 1 lạc tình chăm, nhà giáo giảng giời tại cấp sở,
gạo giúp 1 nón, trường tều học đông trên để bàn xã khu cực 1 tháng, khu cực 2,
phủng đồng vào rất tộc kỳ số và miền lối, xã đạo, hay đạo, xã biên giời được hưởng mất phủ cấp sọng môi thình chăm.
Mất phủ cấp sọng môi thình chăm, cúc được ác dụng với nhà giáo,
cán mộ quan lý cơ sở, gạo giúp công tác, tạo trường năng kỳ, thử dụng thể thao,
trường năng kỳ của nghệ thuật và trường phủ thông dân tập bán chú, cụng lực hưởng mất phủ cấp sọng môi thình chăm.
Huyện cả nước có khoảng 1 phải không năng chợ giáo viên mẩm nón, phủ thông hưởng lương từng năng sách,
trước đó tháng sảo năm 2020 trong tháng 11, cô hội thông qua lật nhà giáo,
quy định nhà giáo được xem lương cáo nhất trong hệ thông thang bật lương thành trình xử nghiệp.